sie schwänzen die schule kippten farbe
auf die straße blockieren banken oder
färben flüsse grünen menschen kämpfen
sie ihre anliegen bisweilen auf sehr
eigenwillige art manchmal auch mit
gewalt darf man das soll man das sogar
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie
die gehen heute der frage nach wie weit
ziviler ungehorsam gehen darf und wobei
eine demokratie auf solche störenfriede
nicht sogar angewiesen ist
ich freue mich sehr dass robin
zertifikates bei uns ist er ist
professor für philosophie an der freien
universität berlin und beschäftigt sich
seit vielen jahren mit protestbewegungen
und zivilem ungehorsam herzlich
willkommen
der celica das waren sie selber schon
auf demonstrationen oder nahmen an
sitzblockaden teil
ja das ist durchaus schon vorgekommen
jetzt möchten wir es gerne genauer
wissen sitzblockaden eher weniger
demonstration schon sehr viel häufiger
ich habe einmal in der sitzblockade in
berlin teilgenommen um eine
demonstration von neonazis durch die
stadt zu blockieren
aber abgesehen davon war ich natürlich
auch vielen demonstrationen zuletzt in
den usa vielleicht gegen die tram
regierung ihre politik und tun sie das
aus überzeugung oder weiß ihr
forschungsgebiet ist ein bisschen zu
beobachten also die genannten beispiele
die ich eben eingeführt habt die habe
ich an der überzeugung teilgenommen als
philosoph ist man ja er jetzt nicht so
in der feldforschung aktiv aber bei dem
thema ist natürlich schon wichtig dass
man auch die protestbewegungen in
gewisser hinsicht aus der nähe studiert
um eben die komplexität der politischen
realität auch dann theoretisch
vielleicht abzubilden insofern habe ich
dann noch an der ein oder anderen
demonstration oder aktionen des zivilen
ungehorsams jetzt eher als teilnehmender
beobachter partizipiert als jetzt allein
aus überzeugung
haben sie auch schon mal einmal etwas
davon benutzt eine spraydose oder ein
cluster stein oder sich irgendwo
angekettet also ohne mich jetzt zu stark
selbst zu bezichtigen hatte ich alle
diese dinge schon mal in der hand aber
eigentlich echt verwendet nur eines
davon nämlich die spraydose und das ist
auch schon ziemlich lange her aber
bisher ich mich jedenfalls nirgendwo
angekettet
kann noch kommen wenn man ihn sonst nur
privat gibt es ja noch ganz andere
protestaktionen vielleicht in ihrem
leben sie sind nämlich vater einer
zweijährigen tochter
da gibt's wahrscheinlich auch viel
zivilen ungehorsam also zumindest also
ob ich in zivil nennen würde weiß ich
gar nicht weil das zum teil schon recht
in zivil der herkommt mit bei dem alter
jetzt geht es auf die temperatur zu zum
teil auch relativ schwierig zu managen
ist aber ja damit bin ich auch aus dem
privaten bereich sehr vertraut bin ja
gespannt wie so ein sozialphilosoph mit
diesen forschungsschwerpunkt dann aus
vater am küchentisch agiert aber gehen
wir zurück zu unserem eigentlichen thema
im moment spricht man ja sehr viel über
zivilen ungehorsam unter anderem
natürlich auch im rahmen der ganzen
klima demonstrationen die files for
future demonstration zb sind in aller
munde wir sehen auch bilder hier von
diesem september aus der schweiz die
klima demonstrationen gesehen das thema
mobilisiert richtig viele massen auch
ganz unterschiedliche menschen alte
menschen junge menschen menschen aus den
unterschiedlichsten schichten gehen auf
die straße
die nächte kaufen sie persönlich diese
regeln also ist natürlich noch relativ
jung hat ein mal habe ich dafür schon
einiges an erfolgen vorzuweisen und ist
insofern schon dadurch es mächtig weil
sie den öffentlichen diskurs glaube ich
schon relevant verändert hat nicht also
das thema ist viel stärker auf der
tagesordnung
das ist noch von zeit war und es ist
auch viel stärker in private
diskussionen eingesickert am
familientisch denen sie gerade schon
genannt hatten
an der uni in einem möglichen kontexten
ist glaube ich die frage was man
angesichts der klimakatastrophe tun kann
viel stärker auf die agenda gekommen was
glaube ich am interessantesten ist an
dieser bewegung ist dass sie eben
hauptsächlich von jungen menschen von
schülerinnen und schülern getragen wird
die damit sich eigentlich als
politisches subjekt jetzt positionieren
und das ist auch ein großer unterschied
zu der
umweltbewegungen aus vergangenen
jahrzehnten mit dem feature oft
verglichen wird aber ich glaube was
neues ist tatsächlich die träger gruppe
in gewisser hinsicht also das ist eben
schülerinnen und schüler sind und junge
menschen die jetzt hier aktiv werden sie
nicht meistens junge menschen also wir
fahren jetzt gar nicht so viel haben uns
trotzdem einen nissan bietet das waren
jetzt vor allem jürgen rentner also
meistens ist es schon eher stärker
gemischt glaube ich und sind sonst
glaube ich auch eher etwas ältere
menschen hier haben wir schon häufig mit
sehr jungen schülerinnen und schülern zu
tun nicht und das ist glaube ich also
quasi noch kinder in vieler hinsicht
das gibt ja auch da hinein dass man dann
sagt man muss das gar nicht ernst nehmen
das sind kinder die damen wir
demonstrieren
das ist so ein bisschen einfach schicken
und schwänzt die schule und geht auf die
straße
was halten sie von diesem vorwurf ja das
ist meines erachtens ein klassisches
ausweichmanöver sozusagen weil damit die
politik oder auch öffentliche medien zum
teil vielleicht etwas hilflos reagieren
auf eine situation mit der sie einfach
nicht genau wissen wie sie umgehen
sollen das zeigt aber glaube ich eher
die macht auch dieser demonstration
dieser bewegung dass sie leute dazu
bringen sie auf diese weise zu
also nicht ernst zu nehmen
das wird aber glaube ich der problematik
und auch der kraft der bewegung nicht
gerecht und ich glaube auch die eine der
leitfiguren greta thunberg für das ja
sehr deutlich vorsehen dass die
politiker in vieler hinsicht alt
aussehen also sprichwörtlich und ich
glaube das feld auf diejenigen zurück
die sie versuchen zu denunzieren als
eben kind das gar nicht weiß wie ernst
die politik ist das keine ahnung hat von
machtpolitik das eben jetzt einfach mal
mit ihrem radikalen forderungen austritt
dann wird er auch häufig in relativ
sexistischer manier irgendwie dass die
tatsache dass ein kleines mädchen ist
das anarchismus hat irgendwie
mobilisiert aber das feld glaube ich
auch in der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
doch auf die politiker gehört und auch
auf die medien zurück die diese
klischees versuchen zu bedienen dass ich
glaube die kraft der bewegung gerade im
symbolischen bereich jetzt vielleicht
noch nicht dass politischer familien
aber gerade die symbolischen bereich es
durchaus beträchtlich und
das macht auch die ethische und
politische gleich wirkmächtigkeit aus
das ist gerade quasi kinder sind die
hier auf die straße gehen aber mit einem
großem ernst auf die straße gehen also
auch gretas rede vor der un
naja da kann man ja im prinzip nicht
lachen ja das war doch mit großem ernst
und damit größer wird mächtigkeit
gesprochen und sie sagen jetzt wenn man
lacht dann ist das ein ausweichmanöver
ein nicht ernst nehmen wollen
es gibt natürlich auch diejenige kritik
die sagt naja es ist auch ein bisschen
ausdruck von doppelmoral also gerade die
riders for future demonstrationen
da wurde oft in der schweiz jetzt gesagt
diejenigen die da teilgenommen haben
waren nachher auch genau dieselben die
dann doch in die ferien geflogen sind
über den sommer hinweg und das ist eine
gewisse frustration die sich bei
gewissen leuten breit macht die sagen
die meinen das ja gar nicht ernst wenn
ich es ernst meinen würden würden die
auch ihr eigenes verhalten ändern ich es
wirklich so ein ausdruck von doppelmoral
also auch das halte ich für relativ
hilflose in relativ hilflos und
versuchte es zu denunzieren oder daran
kritik zu äußern was ich auch für unfair
halte also erst mal müssen man ja
erstmal genauer gucken ob das überhaupt
stimmt nicht also ich bin jetzt ich weiß
ich habe keine zahlen darüber wie viele
der teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
tatsächlich dann urlaub fliegen oder
fleisch essen oder welche
verhaltensweisen partizipieren die
fläche teil des problems sind aber was
viel wichtiger ist es glaube ich dass
crysis verfügt schon extrem schon in
belgien auf ein systemisches oder
strukturelles problem hinweisen nicht
der klimawandel hat natürlich auch was
mit dem verhalten von individuen zu tun
aber da geht es primär um ganz großes
komplexes problem das ich eigentlich nur
durch konzertierte gesetzgebung lösen
lässt er es geht um emissionen von
industrien es geht um natürlich ein
ganzes ökonomisches system auch und das
heißt ob jetzt der eine oder die andere
teilnehmerin an der demo danach fliegt
oder nicht ist eine art von
moralisierung die eigentlich glaube ich
die politische ernsthaftigkeit des
anliegens die dem nicht gerecht wird die
bewegung extinction wie berlin die jetzt
gerade schon erwähnt worden ist auf
deutsch ungefähr rebellion gegen das
aussterben engagiert sich auch gegen den
klimawandel aber mit deutlich
radikaleren mitteln aus die schüler von
freier ist future extinction rebellion
bekennt sich nicht bewusst auch zu
illegalen aktionen auch in der schweiz
gibt
lokal gruppenmitglieder kippen zb
kunstblut auf dem berner bärenplatz zu
hindern weiter auf dem bundesplatz und
legte sich dort auf den boden
im rahmen eines sogenannten dye ins in
der sie sich aus leichen inszenieren
weil wir nämlich alle sterben werden
wenn die politik nicht radikal eingreift
bei einer anderen aktion wurde das
wasser der zürcher limas gift grün
eingefärbt um auf den drohenden kollaps
des ökosystems hinzuweisen
natürlichkeit ist darf man das alles
also zunächst mal glaube ich kann man
festhalten dass das noch relativ
zurückhaltende methoden sind die witze
gesehen haben nicht also sie mögen
vielleicht in der einen oder anderen
hinsicht gegen gesetze verstoßen oder
bestimmte vorschriften erbrechen also
die straßenverkehrsordnung oder so aber
das war jetzt relativ weit entfernt von
echter militanz oder tatsächlich gewalt
förmigen verhalten oder gewaltsam
widerstand nicht es waren alles
symbolträchtige aktionen die auch aus
dem repertoire von protestbewegungen aus
der geschichte zum beispiel dem
aktivismus von aids erkrankten in den
usa da war das da in eine der
bevorzugten intervention formen um
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit zu generieren
die dadurch inspiriert sind insofern
fand ich das jetzt alles beispiele für
zwei zivilen ungehorsam ist also der im
unterschied zu legalen demonstrationen
oder dem verfassen endlich einmal eine
feste tatsächlich mit dem rechtsbruch
einhergeht
aber gleichzeitig waren es sehr stark
begrenzte form des rechtsbruchs also die
primär symbolisch symbolischen
appellcharakter haben genau das können
wir vielleicht schon aufrecht halten zu
zivilem ungehorsam gehört der
rechtsbruch eine demonstration kann man
auch bewilligen lassen meist kriegt man
die auch bewilligt und dann ist polizei
da vielleicht ein bisschen noch
beaufsichtigt aber das ist kein
rechtsbruch ziviler ungehorsam zielt auf
den rechtsbruch und auf einen
symbolischen akt wir haben mit alexandra
gavilan gesprochen von extrem rebellen
schweiz
die hat in einem interview dass wir noch
alles nachlesen kann auf unserer website
esskultur auch gesagt das ziel
eigentlich ist aufmerksamkeit zu erregen
das macht natürlich so ein grüner fluss
also ich glaube dass uns zwei sachen
noch mal wichtig ist eines das
tatsächlich extrem belgien sich
offiziell auch auf gewaltfreien zivilen
ungehorsam
festlegt nicht ob dann alle dem genau
folgenden andere frage ob es zumindest
die selbst festlegung der bewegung
zweitens ist glaube ich wichtig dass die
generierung öffentliche aufmerksamkeit
er tatsächlich der die primäre funktion
schlecht ist oder der primäre effekt
gleichzeitig glaube ich ziehen aber
einige der aktion auch etwas weiter sie
da geht es nämlich darum dass man nicht
nur symbolisch irgendwie zeigt und heute
lebt weil dieses problem ernst sondern
es wird auch versucht damit den gang der
dinge zu unterbrechen oder eine art von
der stärke des aktiven protest diesen
verkehr lahmzulegen oder zum beispiel
auch jetzt werden wir schon die kette
auf dem tisch liegen sozusagen sich
irgendwann zu ketten
in deutschland ist es zum beispiel bei
den protesten gegen den transport von
nuklearmüll sehr prominent dass die
aktivisten auf gleisen zum beispiel
festketten und da gibt es natürlich zum
einen auch um die generierung
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit durch
symbolträchtige aktionen gleichzeitig
hat das aber auch ein stärker direkt
interventionistische moment weil einfach
dadurch die kosten in die höhe getrieben
werden dass nicht nur die symbolischen
kosten und auch die materiellen kosten
der polizei und satz kostet ganz viele
millionen von euros auf irgendeiner
ebene soll damit auch der preis
sozusagen für bestimmte politiken
hochgetrieben werden ja das ist doch
schon mal ein bisschen was anderes als
nur symbolisch zu appellieren an die
mehrheit also fällt die steigerung war
vor mir nicht so ein bisschen
zusammengezuckt dass ich gefragt habe
darf man das haben sie gesagt na ja
alles vergleichsweise harmlos wenn ich
alle finden das harmlos eine giftgrüne
limmat und sich irgendwie gut die farbe
ist biologisch abbaubar und groß auf der
seite aber denkt sich trotzdem na ja das
sind trotzdem aktionen die wärmekosten
die sind eben doch massiv eingreifen und
das braucht man aber andererseits
natürlich um überhaupt öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit zu erhalten nicht also
wenn ich jetzt einfach wieder noch eine
weitere demonstration durchführen würden
oder in einer panel
in der zeitung veröffentlichen da gibt
es dieses phänomen der der erschöpfung
des repertoires ein protest handlungen
also dann nicken die leute einfach sagen
ja klar jetzt demonstrierte halt
irgendwie nochmal eine gruppe also ich
glaube diese spektakuläre seite der der
politik des zivilen ungehorsams die
schon extrem wichtig und dass auch
bewegungen sich immer neue aktionen
überlegen müssen mit denen sie eben
prinzip die leute schocken auch ihre das
ziel ist ja die leute sozusagen aus
ihrer ignoranz oder aus dem wir machen
einfach mal weiter so heraus zu zu
schocken in gewisser hinsicht also immer
noch alles auf symbolischer ebene nicht
also dadurch den grünen schluss wird
hier niemand in seinen interessen
tatsächlich verletzt oder irgendwie
körperlich bedrängt oder so sondern rein
symbolischen ebene angehe angelegt kann
aber auf dieser ebene soll es doch seine
leute heraus schocken aus einer gewissen
einer gewissen sagen einfach in grenzen
halten
dann könnte man ja sagen das ist
eigentlich eine form von
zivilgesellschaftlichem eingreifen
wir haben eine sehr direkte demokratie
es gibt andere möglichkeiten man kann
eine initiative ergreifen man kann sich
politisch engagieren
reicht das nicht aus muss man so
drastische wählen können ja einfach
sagen ey leute macht demokratie sein
also auch da vielleicht zwei punkte dass
der erste ist dass wenn wir uns die
geschichte der demokratie anschauen das
gilt glaube ich jetzt für die schweiz
für deutschland für die usa und viele
andere länder auch dann muss man mich
einfach als soziologisch historische
grund tatsache festhalten dass viele
demokratische fortschritte von denen wir
heute einfach ausgehen dass es sie gibt
also frauenrechte arbeiterrechte soweit
sie gibt überhaupt rechte von
migrantinnen flüchten geflüchteten usw
dass die ergebnisse sind von genau
diesen arten des außer institutionellen
protests ziviler ungehorsam widerstand
und so weiter zum teil ziemlich radikale
form von widerstand so nicht
demokratische mittel gewählt sondern
ganz bewusst ziviler ungehörig versagen
das ist ein demokratisches mittel nur
eben eines das außerhalb der
institutionen situiert ist also ich
glaube man darf den begriff der
demokratie nicht zu stark an die
formalen verfahren war ein parlament und
so weiter binden das ist vielleicht der
institutionelle kern der demokratie aber
darum herum gibt es noch
praktiken und zum teil eben außer
institutionelle oder nicht kommunizierte
praktiken wie zum beispiel soziale
bewegungen zu murasame auch andere
formen des widerstands die historisch
gesehen extrem wichtig waren für die
entwicklung der demokratie
und wenn man diese historische lektion
ernst nimmt dann kann man glaube ich
auch sagen dass auch heute noch
vermutlich solche bewegungen nötig sind
um bestimmte themen auf die agenda zu
setzen wie zum beispiel den klimawandel
und bestimmte stimmen in die diskussion
einzubringen die ansonsten nicht gehört
werden um bestimmte interessen in den
prozess einzuspeisen die nicht
repräsentiert sind also gerade wenn es
um die jüngste generation geht
es gibt ja kein wahlrecht sozusagen für
für kinder und jugendliche nicht also
insofern ist das einfachste argument
dass die schülerinnen schüler von file
is for future oder xing bei den haben zu
sagen wir haben keine andere möglichkeit
wir sind nicht politisch repräsentiert
wir können wir keine eigene partei wenn
wir an dieser brief schreiben ist auch
keiner ernst also müssen wir zu diesen
methoden greifen das hat auch damit zu
tun dass man nicht mehr demokratische
strukturen einfach vielleicht zu
verkrustet sind ein gutes beispiel ist
wahrscheinlich auch rosa parks
die 1955 und montgomery alabama sich
einfach nur geweigert hatte ihren
sitzplatz frei zu geben für einen weißen
fahrgast und eigentlich dadurch dann
massenhaft proteste in gang gesetzt hat
zuerst in die menschen dann nicht mehr
bus gefahren die schwarzen menschen
später kam es dann zur
bürgerrechtsbewegung unter martin luther
king
also man kann eigentlich sagen da hätte
das demokratische normale mittel
möglicherweise nicht ausgereicht und die
nachhinein beurteilen das natürlich auch
richtig die sagt das ist ein sehr gutes
beispiel weil es auch zeigt wie komplex
die situation zum teil sind und wie sehr
wir zum teil auch die geschichte zwar
ein bisschen verzerren oder vielleicht
weichspülen also usa praxis interessant
weil sie am meisten
erinnert wird als diese ältere frau
sobald nämlich schneiderinnen und dann
ist sie plötzlich in diesem moment zur
rebellen geworden ja historische
untersucht haben das ganz gut nur
nachgewiesen dass sie schon lange jahre
aktiv war in bewegungen gegen rassismus
gegen die segregation in den südstaaten
und dass das im prinzip eine handlung
war das gar nicht aus dem nichts kam
sondern tatsächlich
langen traditionen ihres eigenen
handelns innerhalb der bewegung der
bürgerrechtsbewegung auch aufstand und
dass sie insofern viel politische
eigentlich war als sie im nachhinein oft
erinnert wird das interessant weil auch
diese aktion die wir heute für so
paradigmatisch zivil halten
in der damaligen zeit als durchaus und
zivil als überhaupt nicht akzeptabel zum
teil sogar als potenziell touristisch
und so weiter gebrandmarkt worden sind
nicht also auch martin luther king weil
wir mit dem vorwurf konfrontiert auch
von weißer seite und zwar von weißen
liberalen ähnlichen sozusagen
konservativen advokaten dass der
rassistischen segregation sind auf den
meisten liebe rein dass er viel zu
radikal ist ja dass er das sehr viel zu
weit geht das ja doch mal bitte
beschränkung soll auf die existierenden
verfahren aber von denen waren natürlich
schwarz so weitestgehend ausgeschlossen
nun ist das ja ein beispiel wo eine eine
frau etwas getan haben vielleicht nicht
einmal in dem moment die idee habt ihr
jetzt eine belegung loszutreten sie
sagen sie war schon lange aktiv aber
diese eine kleine widerstand hat die
bewegung ins rollen gebracht
währenddessen die extension rebellion
oder auch andere soziale bewegungen
heute eben auch die medien gleich schon
bei gehen gleich schon auf den großen
effekte fielen die auch schon einladen
da kann man auch nachlesen wie der
medien stratege von aixtron berlin
international der äußert sich auch
öffentlich dazu wie sie immer gleich
schon bbc oder den guardian mit
einbeziehen
ist es nicht auch eine gefährdung weil
man sagen könnte die medien als vierte
gewalt haben ja auch eine funktion in
der demokratie wenn sie gleich schon
eingemeindet werden
dann fahren ja die medien wie weg aus na
ja das stimmt wobei ich denke das sagt
genug medien sozusagen als
kontrollinstanz dann ja nicht so
unmittelbar daran beteiligt sind oder
partizipieren
aber auch da glaube ich es wichtig zu
sehen was das immer schon der fall war
so ziemlich haben wir immer vor einem
publikum fand immer findet immer vor
einem publikum statt auch historisch
auch das ist interessant rosa parks war
nicht die erste die diese form des
protests gewählt hatte vorher haben
schon einige andere frauen ausgemacht
die werden die wurden bloß als nicht
sehr präsentabel genug erachtet das war
zum beispiel
eine alleinerziehende mutter die daneben
wo dann gesagt okay wenn wir die jetzt
präsentieren dann mit ihnen fertig
sofort nicht ernst genommen und dann
wird gesagt ja wie kann man so eine frau
die hier nicht mal ordentliches
familienleben aufbauen kann jetzt
irgendwelche normativen appelle ertragen
also auch da hat schon eine rolle
gespielt wie kann man die öffentlichkeit
erreichen wie kann man gerade auch die
weißen moderaten erreichen um sie auf
ihre seite zu ziehen
und insofern spielt das glaube ich immer
noch alle auch für begannen die für alle
beispiele die mir so aufzählen können
aus der langen geschichte des zivilen
ungehorsams war die öffentliche
wahrnehmung der appellcharakter die
frage wie man jetzt die medien weiteren
sinne mit einbezieht sehr relevant
gleichzeitig stimmt es natürlich dass es
heute nochmal andere ausmaße angenommen
hat gerade auch dadurch dass natürlich
über soziale medien und so weiter viel
direktere eine viel direktere
möglichkeit besteht er selbst medien
aufmerksamkeit zu generieren
ich finde das alles so interessante man
ihnen zuhört und irgendwann gibt ja
sozusagen in die frage müssen wir doch
nicht eigentlich mit müssen also viele
würden ja sagen dass sie natürlich jetzt
anliegen war geht es uns ganz große also
diese alexandra graviano sagt in dem
interview auch es geht hier darum dass
wir vor dem sechsten massensterben
stehen wir fahren diesen planeten an die
wand und dann denkt man da ja dann kann
man jetzt auch nicht einfach sagen
sondern die maschine demonstrieren geht
mich nichts an
und so ähnlich argumentiert eigentlich
henry david thoreau das ist einerseits
kann man sagen der vordenker des zivilen
ungehorsams er ist vielen bekannt
aufgrund seiner schrift wahl sind ist
auch so ein bisschen den aussteiger
bibel geworden mittlerweile und erhard
1849 diesen text geschrieben über
zivilen ungehorsam und hat die steuern
nicht bezahlt um zu demonstrieren gegen
die sklaverei damals und hat gesagt ich
trage das nicht mit und er sagt etwas er
sagt nämlich ist aber das gesetz so
beschaffen dass es dich braucht um einem
anderen unrecht zuzufügen so sage ich
bricht das gesetz macht dein leben zur
gegen reibung um die maschine zum hut zu
bringen was immer geschieht ich muss
unbedingt vermeiden mich zu jenem
unrecht herzugeben dass ich verdammt
also der ist ganz klar der meinung wenn
das gesetz oder die institutionen so
beschaffen sind das übel es dabei
rauskommt dann muss sich widerstand
in gewisser hinsicht ja also ich glaube
da muss man jetzt mal ein bisschen
differenzieren weil die pflicht
widerstand zu leisten
suggeriert dass es sozusagen der pflicht
ist etwas zu tun also eine positive
pflicht in dieser hinsicht
während gleichzeitig ja auch davon
spricht dass eine pflicht gibt sich
nicht an unrecht zu beteiligen also sich
sozusagen herauszuziehen und
zurückzuziehen eben nicht zu
partizipieren
und das ist noch mal zwei
unterschiedliche sachen glaube ich also
so ist das in gewisser hinsicht die
perspektive dass man sagt okay wenn das
die situation ist dann ziehe ich mich
einfach zurück in mein häuschen wenn ich
das eben habe sie sich zum beispiel am
wolken und nehmen einfach nicht teil an
dieser gesellschaft die ich zahle
steuern nicht gezahlte steuern nicht
damit auch gegen den krieg der usa gegen
mexiko produziert gegen die sklaverei
auch aber hat sich primär erstmals
zurückgezogen und das auch gar nicht so
weiter kommuniziert dieser text ist erst
ein paar jahre nach seinem akt des
ungehorsams oder vielleicht eher der
verweigerung aus gewissensgründen
publiziert worden
und dann gibt es eben den den
weitergehenden schritt dass man sagt
okay und ich muss was dagegen tun ich
muss mich engagieren ich muss keine
bewegung werden oder eine bewegung
staaten
es gibt andere texte von verloren in der
viel stärker diesen weg nahe legt es
gibt zum beispiel ein text der sehr
interessantes und der auch viel
radikaler ist noch als den den sie jetzt
hier herangezogen haben über captain
john browne das war ein militanter
evolution ist also gegen die sklaverei
sich mit waffengewalt gewehrt und den
hat so quasi auf eine ebene mit jesus
gestellte also moralisch gesehen und da
gibt es um eine apologie gewalt
eigentlich also versagt die situation
ist so schlimm dass eben zu gewalt
greifen müssen um dieses übel zu beenden
das sind schon zwei sehr
unterschiedliche sozusagen auswege aus
der diagnose dir gibt nämlich dass wir
in einem unrechtssystem leben oder das
ernährungssystem gelegt wird genauso ist
eine wäre können wir einfach aufhören zu
partizipieren versus wir müssen uns
engagieren
das zweite er ja noch einmal die frage
welche mittel sind
in ordnung also sind auch gewalttätige
mitglieder darüber möchte ich nachher
gleich ansprechen
ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen bei
dieser pflicht bleiben das war ja auch
eine idee die die bertolt brecht im
vertreten hat sam
wir haben diesen schönen gesagte satz
gesagt wo recht zu unrecht wird wird
widerstand zur pflicht hat sich
natürlich noch stärker jetzt auch gar
nicht auf ungehorsam bezogen sondern auf
den widerstand denken wir an die
résistance während des nazi regimes die
im untergrund versucht haben das vichy
regime zu stürzen
also wird diese pflicht ist
bürgerpflicht gegangen
also auch da ich finde es sehr schwierig
die rede von einer pflicht ist ziemlich
ambivalent in dieser hinsicht also
einerseits ist es so dass viele der
leute die sich engagieren
v leute aus der resisto es jetzt auch
leute die aktiv sind in der
klimagerechtigkeit bewegung
sie sprechen sehr stark von dem
empfinden dass sie eine starke pflicht
haben sich zu engagieren
adwords noten ist ein anderes beispiel
immer sehr stark gesagt er hatte die
pflicht so zu handeln wie er gehandelt
hat
gleichzeitig hat slogan und das gibt es
auch bessere im bewusstsein dafür dass
damit große risiken und kosten
einhergehen und es wurden zum beispiel
sagt sehr deutlich ich verstehe wenn
jemand nicht nach dieser pflicht die ich
selbst sehr stark gespürt habe handelt
ist eine etwas komische pflicht also man
würde denken dass es seine pflicht ist
dann müsste eigentlich jeder dieser
pflichtgemäß handeln und wenn man der
nicht gemäß handelt dann ist man auch
für kritik eigentlich anfällig und muss
sich eben als unmoralisch kritisieren
lassen aber genau diesen weg gehen von
snowden nicht weil sie sagen wir sind
uns das bewusst dass man eigentlich ein
gesamtes leben dafür dann in gewisser
hinsicht geben muss nicht man geht ins
gefängnis man geht ins exil ausloten man
es eigentlich sein leben aufgeben
das ein sehr hoher preis gleichzeitig
ist glaube ich auch sehr wichtig das
glaube ich die pflicht für diejenigen
viel stärker wiegt die in der position
sind etwas zu tun ohne so schlimme
kosten zu gewärtigen nicht also wenn ich
zum beispiel
was ich immer jemand bin der sowieso
schon eine politische oder rechtliche
prekären situation ist nicht also schon
bekannt ohne ohne ohne papiere oder ein
kürzlich geflüchteter dann würde ich
mich oder sagen wir freude amerikaner
den usa ja die setzen sich ganz anderen
risiken aus wenn sie teil einer
politischen bewegungen werden als wenn
ich das als jemanden deutschen passt zum
beispiel tour der letztendlich nicht so
viel vielleicht zu befürchten hat und
ich glaube dass also diejenigen die
sozusagen eine privilegierte position
haben im politisch rechtlichen system
dieser pflicht auch viel stärker
unterliegen und dass andererseits aber
auch diejenigen die durch dieses system
schon die privilegierte oder
benachteiligt kulturell benachteiligt
sind also welche strukturelle
minderheiten oder diskriminierte gruppen
dass die zwar ein größeres recht haben
zum ungehorsam nicht also was sie von
dem system einfach nicht im gleichen
maße profitieren wie andere das tun dass
sie aber nicht unbedingt die gleiche
pflicht haben weil sie eben dadurch ihre
situation noch stärker prekarisierung
würden und sie oft ist das aber genau
umgekehrt dass nämlich diejenigen die
eben gar nicht so getroffen sind und
privilegiert sind auch gar keinen bock
haben sich zu engagieren und auf die
straße zu gehen oder entsprechend sich
auch in gefahrenzonen es vielleicht so
dass und und gleichzeitig ist natürlich
so dass gerade die sowieso schon
benachteiligten gruppen auch viel
stärker bestraft und auch polizeilich
sozusagen betreut werden wenn sie denn
mal auf begehren nicht also ist kann man
in frankreich in den sogenannten bondü
ja sehen
das kann man auch in deutschland sehen
usa auch sehr stark beim umgang mit lars
metter zum beispiel der amerikanischen
bewegungen wo die politik zur reaktion
viel viel härter ausfällt als wenn jetzt
eben weiße college kids irgendwann mal
demonstrieren gehen also diesen
unterschied glaube ich den muss man auch
in philosophischer theoriebildung wohl
ist ein soziologe stellt befunden
erstmal ist auch da viel stärker
berücksichtigt wenn man über das recht
und die pflicht zum oben also redet ich
freue mich über die mittel zum
ungehorsam sprechen möchte möchte ich
noch einmal auf die demokratie zu
sprechen kommen weil man muss sich ja
schon noch einmal deutlich vor augen
führen mann plädiert eigentlich dafür
zusagen der rechtsbuch ist in ordnung
man sagt damit auch kritisches recht
dass rechtliches recht ist nicht
zwangsläufig ein wert an
ich solle es gibt vielleicht ein
moralisches recht was darüber hinausragt
genauso argumentieren beispielsweise
auch soll wurde auch schon was man sagt
es gibt ein moralisches recht das ist
vielleicht bedeutsame und dem fühlen
sich diejenigen verpflichtet die den
rechtsbruch den juristischen rechtsbruch
begehen
das ist immer auch glaube ich ja auch
ein kerzen an rechtsstaatlichkeit oder
ein kratzen am grundpfeilern der
demokratie habermas geht so weit dass er
sagt aber das ist auch ausdruck einer
reifen politischen kultur kann sie uns
das ein bisschen erklären ja also ich
denke dass die rede von einem
moralischen recht oder moralischen
prinzipien auf die man sich im
rechtsbuch bezieht dass es eine weise
ist es zu verstehen was sozusagen die
normative rechtfertigungsgrund lager für
zinn ungehorsam ist der andere
möglichkeit das zu interpretieren die
märz selbst zum beispiel einleuchtend
erscheint es zu sagen na ja demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit wie sie de facto
bestehen stellen den versuch da
bestimmte prinzipien zu
institutionalisieren
die prinzipien der demokratie zum
beispiel freiheit und gleichheit in der
bürgerschaftlichen selbstbestimmung oder
gerechtigkeit prinzipien und insofern
sind die formalen institutionen der
demokratie und des rechtsstaats
tatsächlich keine zwecke an sich sondern
der versuch eben diese prinzipien
umzusetzen
dieser versuch ist aber immer im perfekt
und vor allem fleißig vorläufig nach für
weiterentwicklung offen genauso wie ihr
historisch eine lange entwicklung
durchlaufen musste um zu leben zustands
zu führen denn wir heute haben dabei
immer noch als das team perfekt ist in
verschiedenen sichten und insofern ist
es glaube ich wenn man an der
demokratischen selbst transformation
oder die idee der demokratischen selbst
transformation hin zu mehr demokratie
und so eine demokratisierung der
demokratie festhält
tatsächlich ein ausdruck der reife wie
habe was es sagt dass sich demokratie
neben auf diese form der provokation
einlassen und dass sie das auch einen
gewissen fehlbarkeit bewusstsein machen
dass sie also sagen naja wenn es so war
das in der vergangenheit
protestbewegungen recht darin hatten uns
in residence zu zwingen und stärker zu
demokratisieren dann kann das über ich
heute auch noch der fall sein dass wir
sollten nicht so arrogant
sein oder der hypo anheimfallen dass wir
schon die perfekte demokratie realisiert
haben in dieser hinsicht ist es ein teil
dieses prozesses der demokratisierung
der demokratie dass eben auch formen des
rechtsbruchs und des auslands situation
an dem protest
dazu gehören also könnte man auch sagen
demokratie ist immer arbeit ist immer
ein offenes projekt die offene
gesellschaft muss man immer über neue
verteidigen das ja auch so ein
schlagwort was man noch häufig wird wenn
nun die gegner des zivilen ungehorsams
sagen entschuldigung das ist nicht
ausdruck einer reichen kultur sondern
geradezu sehr unreif und kindisch dann
würden sie sagen na ja ihr habt nicht
verstanden dass man demokratie immer neu
aushandeln muss verstehe ich das richtig
ja so etwas sehen und ich würde dann
gerne von diesen gegnern des regimes
wissen wie sie über die geschichte
demokratie denke weil dann haben sie
eine andere geschichte sozusagen erlebt
die uns zum jetzigen zustand geführt hat
als dieses dieses tatsächlich gegeben
hat meines erachtens zwar eben solche
formen des protests eine wesentliche
rolle spielen ich glaube dass auch
unterschiedliche modelle der
rechtfertigung gibt nicht also es gibt
es gibt natürlich auch religiös
motivierten zu lungenversagen und
ethisch motivierten bessere rovers sehr
stark individualistische das eigene
gewissen bezogen
mir erscheint eigentlich die demokratie
theoretische rechtfertigung wie jetzt
gerade gesprochen hatten wir eigentlich
aussichtsreich ins aussichtsreichsten zu
sein
auch deshalb weil sie und das ist ein
punkt den haaren zum beispiel auch gegen
ferrer macht weil sie sich auf im
prinzip geteilte prinzipien bezieht und
nicht unbedingt auf die eigene einsicht
in die moralische wahrheit gesagt in dem
buch hier auch und wenn ich nur gott auf
meiner seite habe dem recht ist schön
ich weiß dass ich richtig liege bei 99
9% der mitbürgerinnen das anders sehen
das ficht mich überhaupt nicht an
das finde ich eine eher problematische
einstellung in einer demokratischen
gesellschaft nicht erleuchtet mir
eigentlich die demokratie theoretische
rechtfertigung gesagt na ja wir mussten
sich über prozedurale ungerechtigkeiten
ausschlüsse marginalisierung nachdenken
und dekorieren müssen er formal ist oder
prozedurales argument das gar nicht so
sehr auf eine moralische gewissens
wahrheit abzielt die finde ich
eigentlich kompatibel mit einem gewissen
pluralismus an ethischen überzeugungen
ziehen sofern auch aussichtsreiche und
leicht auch sofort ein wenn man sonst
hat sich bei der frage ist wer definiert
eigentlich was dieses
ziel ist dass wir hier reiten und
vielleicht kann man sich da ja auch
täuschen wenn diese diese kontroversen
wird es natürlich sowieso geben nicht
also der streit auch darüber was
demokratie eigentlich ist was sie
erfordert ob wir sie schon haben oder
erst noch erreichen müssen der
begleitete demokratie natürlich auch von
anfang an und dass genau dieser streit
zu dem martin luther king beigetragen
hat zudem die frauenbewegung teil
beigetragen hat zu dem jetzt auch glaube
ich die jüngeren protestbewegung occupy
oder jetzt noch immer frei des verfügt
versuchen bei zum tragen kommen wir auf
die mittel zu sprechen das ist jetzt
schon öfters angeklungen auch wenn wir
hier die steine sehen nicht alle
protestaktionen verlaufen friedlich auch
wenn es eben zu zivilem ungehorsam
eigentlich aus einem kriterium
dazugehört gewaltfrei zu sein ist die
grenze fließend und wir wissen alles
gibt protestaktionen die sind massiv
gewalttätig wir können zb an die
ausschreitungen anlässlich des
g20-gipfels in hamburgerinnen 2017 war
das massive zerstörung und haben und gut
von geschäften usw oder auch die
brennenden autos der chinesen in paris
die sich eingebrannt haben glaube ich
uns ins kollektive gedächtnis die schule
schon die protestieren gegen die elitäre
politik gegen den mittelstand der keine
chance mehr hätte gegen die besteuerung
des treibstoffs und so weiter was würden
sie sagen macht gewaltaktionen immer
unrecht und ich meine jetzt moralische
recht also sich zwei punkte wichtig das
erste ist dass das war natürlich jetzt
bilder der gewalt zum großteil von
demonstranten ausgehen und werden auch
ein paar bilder der gewalt von polizei
gegen demonstranten gesehen
die gab es auch bei den g20-protesten
also immer die frage welche gewalt
spricht man gerade natürlich wird
meistens die gewalt demonstrieren wenn
stärker fokussiert als vielleicht die
gewalt der polizei gegen friedliche
demonstranten die nicht nur bei den
religionen aber auch bei den 20
demonstrationen zum vielen perfektion
geführt hat sondern auch zur
einschränkung des rechts auf
demonstrationen zum beispiel das auch
alles gut dokumentiert also man muss
glaube ich wenn man über gewalt spricht
immer die gewalt von verschiedenen
seiten im blick behalten wobei natürlich
die polizei immer sagen würde wir
reagieren
ja gut aber die sagen natürlich beides
hätten also auch da glaube ich muss man
muss man immer vorsichtig sein und
hinschauen genau hinschauen und der
zweite punkt der glaube ich wesentlich
ist bevor man zu der normativen frage
kommt die die natürlich zentral ist der
zweite punkt ist über welchen begriff
der gewalt reden wir eigentlich an es
gibt ja sehr unterschiedliche formen von
gewalt nicht und nicht alle sind
engländer nicht alle haben den gleichen
normativen implikationen also die gewalt
gegen sachen den autos bushaltestellen
bankgebäude
er ist eine sache und sollte von der
gewalt gegen personen unterschieden
werden wird aber häufig in eins gemischt
und dann wird so getan als sei beides
gleich schlimm und als würde würden sich
protestbewegungen notwendigerweise
sofort disqualifizieren weil sie eben
zum beispiel gewalt gegen sachen
involvieren
auch bei der gewalt gegen personen das
ist glaube ich wichtig zu unterscheiden
zwischen sagen wir minimaler gewalt zum
beispiel im zurück schubsten von einem
polizeibeamten bestehen kann der mit dem
knüppel auf einen los geld vielleicht
ist es auch eine form der gewalt es war
doch eine ganz andere also wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel ein pflasterstein
nehme und irgendwie auf einen
ungehemmten polizisten werfe der einfach
irgendwie streife geht oder so und
drittens gibt es die gewaltigen sich
selbst die auch in protestbewegungen
zentrale rolle gespielt hat also denken
sie daran wie der arabische frühling das
sogenannte arabische frühling begonnen
hat mit der selbstverbrennung schon mal
mit bouazizi es auch eine form der
gewalt die auch von vielen als
schockierend und zivil und zweiter
gesehen wird aber ich glaube gerade
gewalt gegen sachen vielleicht minimale
gewalt in selbstverteidigung zum
beispiel gegen polizei aggressionen und
gewalt gegen sich selbst sind durchaus
kompatibel mit der zivilität des zivilen
ungehorsams also ich glaube nicht dass
sie will unbedingt heißt gewaltfrei im
striktesten sinne das heißt verzicht auf
bestimmte formen der gewalt zum beispiel
massive gewalt die auf die körperliche
verletzung anderer zielt aber ich glaube
dass zum beispiel vision gefallen der
sachbeschädigung durchaus kompatibel
sind
das heißt nicht dass immer
gerechtfertigt dass in dem zuerst
verstehen was heißt hier zivilität also
wenn gewalt kompatibel ist mit zivilität
das verstehe ich unter zivilität also
das natürlich einer der zentralen fragen
der gesamten diskussion über zu
und tatsächlich ist es so dass bei
bestimmten orten wie holz oder habermas
der schluss vom zivilen auf das
gewaltfreie sehr schnell geht und auch
ohne jede diskussion übrigens des
gewalttäters nicht also die unterstellen
einfach wissen alle schon was gewalt ist
und irgendwie es intuitiv plausibel zu
sagen zivil heißt gewaltfrei ich glaube
aber dass das so schnell geht also zivil
heißt glaube ich vor allem dass man sich
als zugehörig zu einer politischen
gemeinschaft begreift und dass man mit
der anderen seite ob das ist ein die
polizei ist in der konkreten situation
oder der politische gegner das man sich
als gemeinsam zugehörig zu dieser
gemeinschaft begreift um auch in zukunft
begleiten will dass man also mich auf
die vernichtung oder den ausschluss der
anderen seite abzielt diese anerkennung
des anderen als teil der gleichen
politischen gemeinschaft als bürger sind
als bürger ist aber glaube ich durchaus
kompatibel zum beispiel damit dass eben
bestimmte form der sachbeschädigung
stattfinden ist noch kompatibel damit
dass man gewalt gegen sich selbst
anwendet ist das genau kompatibel warum
darf ich wenn meine anliegen legitim
sind und vielleicht eine idee von
demokratie dienen also ich will zum
beispiel gerechtigkeit sagen jetzt mal
von außen betrachtet in einem sinnvollen
in einer sinnvollen weise
weiterentwickelt warum darf ich darf
hier die sachen von anderen menschen
kaputt machen
naja also auch da muss man natürlich
erstmal noch einmal stark differenzieren
glaube ich und es also zum beispiel wenn
man jetzt die existenzgrundlage von
einzelhändlern zerstörten ist es
natürlich normativ deutlich bedenklicher
als wenn wir jetzt sagen wir symbolisch
die fassade einer bank kaputt macht also
es geht ja nicht darum dass ich sage das
wollen wir unbedingt machen oder das ist
in jedem fall gerechtfertigt wird nur
zeigen dass die frage der rechtfertigung
nicht damit erledigt ist dass man sagt
hier findet sachbeschädigung statt
dieser schluss ist viel zu einfach
glaube ich nicht und dann hängt es von
sehr vielen faktoren abhängt von der
zielsetzung des protestes ab es hängt
von der art und weise des gewalteinsatz
ist wenn man das so nennen möchte
ob es hängt davon ab ob diese zum
beispiel die form der sachbeschädigung
tatsächlich irgendwie zielführend ist
oder nicht in vielen fällen ist
natürlich nicht und ist tatsächlich eine
form des vandalismus
damit ist sehr problematisch wird
aber ich glaube dass man diese frage
ernst nehmen müssen dass man sie nicht
vor entscheiden darf indem man sagt
zivil heißt gewaltfrei also ist jede
form der gewalt im weitesten sinne
gewaltigen sachen wenn uns durchaus
diskussion darüber auf dass gewalt im
strikten sinne ist oder oder eben nicht
ein mittel ist manchmal auch dass man
auf den mann auf die frau spielt es gab
zum beispiel militante tierschützer
dieser ferienhaus von ihren vasella
novartis chef beschädigt haben
eigentlich zerstört haben um auf
tierversuche aufmerksam zu machen hat
übrigens dann auch empirisch auch gar so
gar nicht gestimmt aber grundsätzlich
ist das ja noch einmal etwas anderes
wenn man wirklich das eigentum einer
konkreten person geschädigte genau das
ist durchaus ein anderes auch da weiß
ich nicht ob das in allen fällen
notwendigerweise ungerechtfertigt ist
aber es hat zumindest sehr viel stärkere
begründungspflicht damals zufolge als
wenn man jetzt eben tatsächlich sich auf
was ich aber eben eine
straßenbahnhaltestelle oder autos die da
gepackt sind ohne jetzt zu wissen wem
die gehören beschränkt aber wie gesagt
also ich glaube das team die die frage
einfach nur eröffnet werden muss was
davon jetzt legitim sein kann was nicht
ohne schon vor zu entscheiden in vielen
fällen ist es natürlich kontraproduktiv
und dann da muss man dann eben sowohl
moralischer als auch strategische
erwägungen glaube ich immer mit
berücksichtigen
ich versuche mal von der anderen seite
her zu argumentieren sie sind professor
für philosophie an der freien
universität in berlin ihnen kann nicht
viel passieren sie sind verbeamtet
sie haben ein gutes auskommen versetzen
sie sich mal in die lager derjenigen
dieser bank die am morgen dahin kommen
das ist alles rot verschmiert das sind
irgendwelche vermuten leute oder auch
nicht vermummt die haben sich dahin
gekettet riesenskandal was denke ich in
der rolle
und was würden sie ihnen sagen kann ich
ihn einfach sehr ruhig mal das ist
ausdruck von demokratie ja also ich habe
auch schon an universitäten gearbeitet
die lange zeit besetzt werden durch
studierende im rahmen von
protestbewegungen und finde auch das
legitim unter bestimmten umständen auch
wenn es unangenehm sein mag ich finde es
auch legitim wenn ich im auto sitze und
irgendwo zum flughafen fahren zb und
dann ist eine straßenblockade auf
und einer demonstration dann ist es
natürlich in dem moment vielleicht
ärgerlich aber ich glaube schon dass man
erwarten kann auch von individuell
betroffenen dass sie sozusagen die den
schritt auf die nächste ebene gehen und
sich eben überlegen zu welchem zweck
passiert ist hier eigentlich und warum
machen dass die leute nicht machen dass
er in vielen fällen zumindest nicht
einfach aus spaß oder nicht einfach aus
eigeninteresse sondern eben weil sie
glauben dass die ernsthaftigkeit ihres
anliegens ihm keine andere wahl lässt
weil sie glauben dass andere mittel und
wege in nicht offen stehen
und weil sie denken dass allein auf
diese art und weise eben zum beispiel
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit generiert
werden kann
ich weiß nicht ob die angestellten der
bank diese argumentationsweise unbedingt
offen gegenüberstehen würden aber ich
glaube schon dass sie dass man mit ihnen
in dieser hinsicht eher reden müsste
auch weil natürlich zumindest in vielen
fällen auch nicht in allen fällen mit
vielen fällen die leute die tatsächlich
dann demonstrieren oder dieses risiko
auch für sich selbst eingeben
jetzt ebenfalls in den wenigsten fällen
universitätsprofessoren sind sondern
selbst leute die jetzt nicht unbedingt
aus den besten sommer situation
ökonomisch politisch gesprochen heraus
agieren sondern eben weil sie denken
dass sie keine angewandt haben
man merkt schon dass ja
sozialphilosophen tauss ein spezialist
für dieses thema relativ großzügig sind
auch mit der erlaubten zivilen
ungehorsam sagen auch dass sie den
gewalt begriff gerne ein eigentlich
möglichst eng verstehen wollen und auch
sagen wollen
es ist gleich dann wirklich nicht
legitime militärische gewalt geht nun
könnte man ja auch sagen na ja wenn wir
es ganz loslösen jetzt mal zum ziel es
gibt auch oder oder eben nicht loslösen
funktioniert das ziel mit hineinnehmen
es gibt ja auch die ganzen
protestaktionen von rechts denken wir an
die protestmärsche in chemnitz
beispielsweise gegen mehr zuwanderung
gegen mehr migration
auch das ist eine form von zivilem
ungehorsam sind sie da gleich großzügig
oder bauen sie ihre politischen
präferenzen schon mit ein
also ich versuche natürlich meine
politischen präferenz nicht in die
theoretische reflexion mit einzubauen
und ich denke auch nicht dass ist
wirklich eine frage der
großzügigkeit ist sondern eine frage wie
diese begriffe adäquat verwendet werden
und ich glaube dass man schon allein auf
der grundlage zum beispiel in einem fall
der chemnitzer ausschreitungen muss man
dir nennen und nicht nur demonstrationen
er sagen kann das einfach aufgrund des
begriffs das ziel ungehorsams ist kein
ziviler hubschrauber
es war natürlich ungehorsam vielleicht
auch widerstand oder protest aber der
begriff des zivilen genau wie ich im
vorhinein geführt habe schließt glaube
ich aus radikal rechte oder
neonazistische bewegungen darunter
fallen zu lassen weil sie gerade nicht
die andere seite akzeptieren als teil
der gemeinschaft sondern gerade auf die
auf den ausschluss die entrechtung zum
teil auch die vernichtung internierung
und so bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen zum
beispiel von allen die sie eben als
nicht deutsch imaginieren abzielen also
das ist glaube ich sowohl von der
zielsetzung her als auch zum teil
jedenfalls von den mitteln also hetzjagd
zum beispiel auf anders aussehende ganz
klar so dass es außerhalb des zivilen
selbst in einer erweiterten fassung
fällt nicht also ich glaube schon dass
es sowohl begrifflich als auch politisch
extrem wichtig ist da genau zu sein und
der ziert aber von beiden seiten oder
das gibt ja auch wenn links natürlich
klar und ich glaube auch ich habe wenn
sie bestimmte beispiele gesprochen bei
denen das glaube ich so ist dass der
begriff des zivilen ungehorsams zutrifft
und zwar nicht weil ich jetzt die
zielsetzung teile sondern einfach weil
ich es für philosophische und
begrifflich plausibel halten das so so
zu fassen natürlich gibt es auch
bewegungen von links die außerhalb des
bereichs dass sie wieder angesiedelt
sind
und das kann in bestimmten fällen
natürlich gerechtfertigt sein anderen
ist es nicht gerechtfertigt nicht also
wenn wir uns jetzt kontext vor augen
führen die nicht so demokratisch und
rechtsstaatlich wie imperfekt auch immer
organisiert sind wie zum beispiel die
schweiz und deutschland sind natürlich
auch form des protestes ist widerstands
auf der tagesordnung die über das ziel
hinaus gehen nicht die können genauso
legitim sind also denken sie an
revolutionen form des bewaffneten
widerstands antikolonialen kämpfe usw
die war natürlich
also ich würde sagen natürlich
gerechtfertigt in vielen hinsichten
stellen natürlich aber eine ganz andere
form des politischen handelns ist also
der zivile ungehorsam ist eine kategorie
die wenn man mit allen sprechen möchte
diesen geist des revolutionären
innerhalb eines mehr oder weniger
demokratisch organisierten gemeinwesens
wachhalten möchte oder eben praktisch
realisiert werden lässt und damit nimmt
er eine seltsame zwischen stellung ein
nicht als er ist auf der einen seite
eben nicht dasselbe wie rechtmäßiger
protest auf der anderen seite ist es
eben auch nicht dasselbe wie eine
revolutionäre erhebung nicht hat ebenso
zwischen stellung und das macht ihnen
glaube ich so interessante möchte ich
auch das führt natürlich auch dazu dass
also auch gruppen die glaube ich keinen
anspruch haben dieses label zu nutzen
wie zum beispiel radikale rechte oder
neonazistische bewegung versuchen diesen
begriff zu capture in dieser hinsicht
weil er natürlich ein gewisses
legitimation spencer nach mit sich
bringt nicht also menschen also zu ihren
damit kann die bewegung der politische
rechtfertigung heute eigentlich mehr
außer frage steht
vielleicht haben sie noch einmal einen
satz dazu was haben sie einen neonazi
warum seine form des protestes nicht
legitim ist
also ich glaube da muss man auf zwei
ebenen argumentieren das eine ist die
zielsetzung also einfach sozusagen die
der ausschluss bestimmter
bevölkerungsgruppen aus der politischen
gemeinschaft die zum teil vernichtungs
rhetorik die da mobilisiert wird
entrechtung also dass man einfach leuten
staatsbürgerschaft gericht und so weiter
aber kennen möchte also das scheint mir
offensichtlich dass das nicht kompatibel
ist mit irgendeinem verständnis von
demokratie oder visibilität und
gleichzeitig auch viele der mitte die
gewählt werden also das zusammenschlagen
und verfolgen öffentliche hetze akten
auf
heute veranstalten das ist doch was sehr
anderes als auch die zum teil seiner
relativ minister bilder die wir jetzt
hier gesehen haben von den protesten
über die wir vorher geredet haben ich
glaube sowohl auf der ebene der
zielsetzung also auf die ebene der mitte
und ich glaube ja auch auf der ebene
sagen wir der form des zivilen
ungehorsams gibt es da massive
unterschiede nicht also dass
rechtsradikale gruppen sehr häufig
extrem hierarchisch organisiert sind auf
für ihre figuren hin die dann sozusagen
top-down befehle durch geben ob jetzt in
kleinen zellen wie eben dem
nationalsozialistischen untergrund oder
in grösseren organisationsformen wie der
afd
und auch das ist ein deutlicher
unterschied zumindest einige mehr
demokratie kompatiblen oder pro
demokratischen bewegung also zum
beispiel occupy 3ds verfügt viele der
anderen bewegung sind viel weniger
hierarchisch organisiert viel inklusive
möglichen formen der selbstkritik und
selbstreflexion auf viel stärkere art
und weise als das in radikal rechten
bewegungen der fall ist wo im prinzip
die abschließen und auch die identitäts
fixierung deutlich stärker ausgeprägt
sind
sprechen wir zum schluss noch über die
frage wie eigentlich politischer
ungehorsam wirklich erfolgreich seine
ziele dann erreichen kann
gerade im rahmen der klimademonstration
gibt es ja viele jetzt auch kann man
vielleicht was schon sagen depressive
stimmen denken die uns schon zum
pflanzen der einen artikel im new yorker
veröffentlicht hat und wirklich so von
einer globalen depression gesprochen hat
die leute haben das gefühl bringt
irgendwie alles nicht das gibt es auch
nicht demonstrationen aber wie sie
selber gesagt haben der individuelle
beitrag scheint minikleid zu sein wenn
ich nicht mehr viele und kein fleisch
mehr essen scheint der beitrag so klein
zu sein wir müssen die institutionen
ändern
wann reichen den demonstrationen aus um
so ein system wirklich zu kehren was
macht solche protestaktion erfolgreich
also ich glaube aus der geschichte kann
man lernen dass es natürlich keine
zauberformel gibt also es ist nicht so
dass man sagen kann wir müssen dies und
das tun und dann werden wir schon
erfolgreich sein sondern das hängt immer
von unglaublich viel
context faktoren ab gleichzeitig wehrte
geschichte auch finde ich ebenfalls
einen vorsichtigen optimismus einfach
deshalb weil zum teil
das politisch neue und vielleicht
revolutionäre transformative auch gerade
dann entsteht oder sich ereignet wenn
man es nicht vermutet nicht also der
sogenannte arabische frühling hat es ja
schon im namen als sei da sozusagen
etwas plötzlich gekommen was sozusagen
gar nicht sich angekündigt hatte
natürlich gab es eine vorgeschichte die
wird auch oft vergessen aber eben solche
oder die sogenannten friedlichen
revolution von 1989
diese ereignisse wurden von sehr wenigen
leuten vorhergesagt nicht also das neue
revolutionäre kann sich eben das ist
auch eine lektion die haben wir sind
glaube ich sehr richtig erkannt hat im
prinzip immer ereignet
das würde ich zumindest als vorsichtigen
optimismus mit einem debatte einbringen
gleichzeitig ist natürlich so dass die
aussichten im moment jedenfalls nicht
besonders gut sind einfach kommt der
komplexität der weltpolitischen lage
nicht also mit regierungen mit kramp in
den usa in brasilien der rechten werden
den vielen ländern europas ist natürlich
jetzt erstmal so dass diese
demonstrationen nicht unbedingt da gehör
finden das ist muss vorsichtig
formulieren
aber gleichzeitig sind diese bewegungen
eben auch glaube ich auf einen erfolg
der längerfristig eigentlich gedacht
werden muss angelegt nicht also die
kurzfristigkeit das erfolgsdenken uns da
nicht ein problem also auch okay ist
natürlich nicht erfolgreich gewesen hat
aber doch die diskussion über zum
beispiel ökonomischer ungleichheit was
sie verändert genau das hat glaube ich
weil es so viele stellen diese
diskussion verändert das ist noch nicht
beendet denn das ende des weges aber es
ist zumindest ein einschritt und die
arabische frühling den erwähnt ja auch
in vielen ihrer texte eigentlich noch
auf gutes positives beispiel ist auch
noch ein bisschen die texte zum frühjahr
entstanden
aber heute werden viele sagen der ist
eigentlich gescheitert ja sicher einen
gewissen hinsichten ist er ohne zweifel
gescheitert ob das jetzt besser gewesen
wäre es hätte ihn nie gegeben das ist
noch mal eine andere
frage für mich auch weil das scheitern
natürlich viele faktoren hat nicht also
auch vielleicht die haltung des westens
und so weiter gleichzeitig ist es aber
glaube ich eben wichtig also man kann
kann hat mit einem punkt glaube ich was
sehr wichtig ist ein solches reduzieren
revolutionären momenten sie das ist so
etwas vergisst sich nicht ja das lenkrad
im geschichts zeichen dass bestehen
bleibt auch als referenzpunkt für
jüngere generationen die dann eventuell
ist eben noch einmal versuchen und das
ist glaube ich habe schon frühling der
fall das ist bei optimaler fall ist bei
vielen protesten der fall wo ganz neue
generationen aktiv werden die eigentlich
zum ersten mal auch völlig überraschend
sich sich politisieren und das ist auch
die hoffnung finde ich die es mit trail
ist für otto und extrem schnelle berlin
einhergeht dass da genau dann auch ein
neuer politischer akteur entsteht und
dass man an dem glaube ich im prinzip
jedenfalls im nächsten jahr nicht
vorbeikommen ob es dann ausreicht ob das
schnell genug geht das wissen wir
natürlich nicht aber wir können uns
glaube ich nicht erlauben es nicht zu
versuchen wir es schaffen dass es
funktionieren würde es gibt eine zahl
die hat mich erstaunt es gibt nämlich
eine sozialwissenschaftlerin aus den usa
eric genovese die koryphäe auf diesem
gebiet die und dass uns diese bewegung
die sagt 3,5 prozent der bevölkerung
müssen eigentlich die anliegen teilen
einer protestgruppe dann kann das ganze
erfolgreich werden
das scheint mir waren sie nicht wenig zu
sein wenn ich an die frauenbewegung
denke will ich jetzt mal sagen einige
mehr aus 3,5 prozent teilen zb das
anliegen der gleichen löhne trotzdem
passiert nicht so wahnsinnig viel oder
sind sie immer noch nicht am ziel
also ich glaube auch dass das man mit
diesen mittelwerten vorsichtig sein muss
nicht also das hängt sehr stark vom
kontext ab 3,5 prozent in hongkong haben
vielleicht eine andere art von
wirksamkeit als 3,5 prozent in der
schweiz oder auf nationaler ebene das
ist eine sache auf regionaler ebene oder
in der stadt eine andere
das meine ich eben es gibt keine keine
zauberformel dafür und ich glaube dass
es sicherlich in vielen hinsichten auch
davon abhängt welches anliegen von
welcher gruppe gepusht wird also wenn
wir jetzt die frauenbewegungen nehmen
wie in ihrem beispiel
dann musste die sicher durchsetzen gegen
massive gesellschaftliche
machtstrukturen und eine sehr große
gruppe in der bevölkerung nämlich männer
die ihre privilegien wahrscheinlich ja
auch hartnäckig verteidigt hatten eine
ganze zeit lang und wenn sie so in der
situation dass dem rechnung 35 prozent
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich nicht wenn es
eine andere situation ist in der eine
mächtige gruppe ihre privilegien
vielleicht nicht so ohne weiteres
aufgeben muss um die situation zu
verändern wir müssen vielleicht viel
einfacher zu gestalten und dies ist bei
diesem klima demonstration nicht das
problem dass ihr alle unsere privilegien
verlieren werde
natürlich das ist die große
herausforderung dass es nach einem sehr
radikalen wandel des ökonomischen
systems der lebensweise die jetzt auf
kosten anderer welt teile schon jetzt
und natürlich auf kosten zukünftiger
generationen oder der jungen generation
die jetzt schon lebt geht dass die
radikal geändert werden müssten und da
sind natürlich viele interessen im spiel
auch von großindustrie regierungen und
so weiter nicht nur von uns ein sondern
auch vom mächtigen gesellschaftlichen
gruppen die sich natürlich dagegen
wehren so wehr setzen werden um die
blicke sind die zukunft sie haben am
anfang des gesprächs noch gesagt es gibt
diese ermüdungserscheinungen von
sozialen bewegungen man kann ja jetzt
beides sich überlegen frei des future
und extension berlin wird irgendwann
müde und wird wieder einschlafen die
leute werden sich wieder anderen dingen
zuwenden und dann wird entweder alles
ganz schlimm oder es passiert dann doch
nichts
oder das ganze radikalisiert sich extrem
was haben sie für wahrscheinlich
also wir sind ja dann mit einer ganz
besonderen situation konfrontiert weil
anders als bei anderen problemen auf die
soziale bewegungen reagieren das problem
des klimawandels ja eher zu einem
zunehmenden problem druck führen wird in
den nächsten jahren
und insofern ist glaube ich schon in der
strukturellen gesamtsituation angelegt
dass diese bewegung ob es diese zwei
spezifische oder neue formationen uns
auch in zukunft begleiten werden naja
also wetterphänomene die uns alle
stärker direkt
treffen werden natürlich in
unterschiedlichen welten unterschiedlich
aber auch hier merkt man was von den
heißeren sommern von stärkeren gewittern
von klimakatastrophen kleinerer und
größerer art und das wird natürlich wenn
man den prognosen der wissenschaftler
glauben schenkt alles im nächsten jahren
schon deutlich spürbarer werden ich
glaube in dieser hinsicht gibt es
sozusagen eine an der objektivität des
problems die auch noch stärker jetzt zum
beispiel in der bürgerrechtsbewegung
einfach unausweichlich ist nicht also
man kann das nicht so einfach zur seite
wischen das wird zunehmend schwieriger
glaub ich
und diese hätten sich das glaube ich
glaube ich auch die bewegungen die sich
auf dieses problem ausrichtet in zukunft
unterschiedliche form an dem ich finde
ich sehr interessant das ist ja diese
beiden formationen gibt nicht also
feiert ist verfügt ja sozusagen die er
auf demonstration setzen und exotische
rebellen berlin die etwas sie gesagt hat
ein radikaler sich positionieren
die aber durchaus auch zueinander
sprechen und es auch als dieser mann
sagen also kooperationen begreifen dass
eben weil man sozusagen eine eine
radikalere flanke hat und eine etwas
gemäßigter wir um eben auf mehreren
leuten verschiedenen bevölkerungsgruppen
auf die teilnahme zu ermöglichen
ansprechpartner zu finden und so weiter
ich würde ich auch in zukunft damit
rechnen dass es diese beiden strategien
sage ich mal gibt oder ausrichtungen die
eher sagen kommunikative und der
destruktive die zukunft ist offen wir
müssen sie gestalten ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch
erzählt es danke ich drücke ihm ja
nächste woche wählt die schweiz ein
neues parlament
und ich frage wer oder was bringt unsere
politik und unsere gesellschaft voran
zu gast sind die soziologin cornelia
koppetsch und der philosoph dieter thoma
der in seinem neuen buch neue helden
fort und jetzt gleich begegnen sie der
sternstunde musik den neuen
chefdirigenten des tonhalle orchesters
zürich
der charismatische mann aus island
sorgte schon vor seinem amtsantritt für
begeisterung zu recht sehen sie selbst
eine gute woche bis bald
[Musik]